Speaker 1: Some of you may remember that Donald
Trump is being sued by author E Jean Carroll for
defamation and for sexual assault. And this is
all related to an alleged encounter in the 1990s.
Truth is sometimes stranger than fiction. We have
now learned that Donald Trump mistook an image
of Jean Carroll for his own ex-wife, Marla maples,
in a deposition that took place at Mar a Lago last
year. Now know Trump has argued, I wouldn't have
sexually assaulted Jean Jean Carroll because she's
not my type. Now, a lot of people might react
and say, I don't sexually assault people, so it
doesn't matter what the woman looks like because
I don't sexually assault people. No. Okay, fine.
Trump said I wouldn't have done it because she's
not my type. Fine. So the fact that he thought it
was his ex-wife suggests maybe she actually is his
type. It's unbelievable. There's a Washington Post
article by Shayna Jacobs. Trump Thought Photo
of Accuser was of Ex-wife during deposition.
Donald Trump mistook his sexual assault
accuser, Jean Carroll, for his ex-wife,
Marla maples, when shown a photograph from the
1990s in a deposition at Mar a Lago last year,
potentially undermining one of the common
defenses he has used to deny an attack. Trump,
who is being sued by Carroll for defamation and
sexual assault stemming from the same alleged
encounter, has repeatedly said Carroll is not
his type, suggesting an assault could not have
occurred because he would not have pursued her
romantically. That's Marla. Yeah, that's my wife,
Trump said when he was examined by Carroll's
lawyer, Roberta Kaplan, in a new selection of
excerpts from the deposition that was unsealed.
Trump's blunder in a sworn deposition was quickly
corrected by his attorney, Aleena. Habre, who
told him it was Carroll, not Maples. Maples
was Trump's second of three wives. Trump did not
immediately have a comment. The black and white
photo at issue has been circulating since Carroll
made the allegations detailing an account in her
memoir of a forced sexual act. Trump has denied
ever knowing her, said, She's not my type. Okay.
We all know that this is a stunning situation.
And if this didn't deal with things as serious
as sexual assault, we could all just be laughing
at it. But one of the ways that Trump has tried
to dismiss these allegations and dismiss and
undermine the credibility of Jean Carroll has
been to say she's simply not my type. I'm not
attracted to her. I wouldn't have been attracted
to her in the nineties. He is basically saying she
is not desirable enough for me to even pursue her,
never mind forced myself upon her or something
like that. Here we learn. Oh. An image of her
in the nineties Trump actually believed was his
own ex-wife, someone who I would assume Trump
was romantically and sexually interested in. Now,
the bigger problem, of course, is that this entire
line of reasoning perpetuates some really horrible
societal stereotypes about women and sexual
assault. And it when Trump mistakes his accuser
for his ex-wife, it not only continues to go
along that line, which is like, was she attractive
enough for Trump to sexually assault her or not?
Right. Which is like a crazy conversation to
be having. But it also more generally raises
questions about whether anything Trump says can be
believed. Whether any of Trump's defenses can be
believed when they might be based on complete
misapprehensions by Donald Trump. Altogether,
this is not the first time Trump has been
accused of sexual assault. He has a history of
denying allegations, undermining the credibility
with similar statements. Not my type wouldn't
have done it, that sort of thing. I don't know
whether this is going to go anywhere. But Trump,
mistaking the accuser for his own
ex-wife, is really wild, wild stuff.